und in cloppenburg begrüße ich die
stellvertretende cdu vorsitzende silvia
breher guten tag
frau bär am freitag hat armin laschet ja
sein zukunftsteam vorgestellt dem sie
zuständig für familienpolitik angehören
mal hand aufs herz mit wie viel
zeitlichem vorlauf haben sie davon
erfahren wurden sie dafür angefragt
also wir sprechen natürlich regelmäßig
mit armin laschet wird telefonieren auch
und dass etwas geplant ist das war
durchaus mit den meisten von uns früh
abgestimmt aber den termin haben wir
kurzfristig festgesetzt genau wie die
medien ja warum haben sie sich dann
verpflichten lassen trotz oder gerade
wegen der schlechten umfragewerte für
die union
aus überzeugung ich bin teil der cdu und
wenn ich helfen kann für die union
wahlkampf zu machen dann sage ich
natürlich ja nun sondern bei dieses
zukunftsthema ausdrücklich kein
schattenkabinett sein aber wie sollen
sie sich da inhaltlich profilieren wenn
sie keine alternativen zur jetzigen
familienpolitik der bundesregierung
vorlegen dürfen
die jetzige familienministerin
ist nur eine kommissarische oder frau
lamprecht macht es mit wir haben gar
keine cdu familienministerin insofern
ist es für uns einfach wichtig auch die
familienthemen mal in den mittelpunkt zu
stellen denn familien kinder eltern aber
auch senioren hat es einfach verdient
und uns ist wichtig dass wir auch dieses
thema in unserem regierungsprogramm mal
breiter aufstellen und einfach mal
präsentieren dann nennen sie doch mal
wenigstens einen punkt den sie als
künftige eventuelle familienministerin
anders machen würden
familien brauchen kein schema f kein
entweder vollzeit arbeiten oder vollzeit
zu hause bleiben wir sollten öfter auf
die familien selber hören was sie
wirklich wollen und familien wünschen
sich vor allen dingen zeit mehr zeit für
die familie für die kinder für die
organisation zu hause und unser ansatz
ist da die einführung von familien
arbeitszeiten also familienzeit konnten
wo einfach noch flexibler am ende
familie und job kombiniert werden kann
und insgesamt wollen wir dazu das
elterngeld ausweiten die partnermonate
beim elterngeld ausweiten
flexibilisieren damit familien
tatsächlich mehr zeit füreinander haben
ist ja ein bisschen fraglich ob sie
genau diese punkte als
familienministerin würden umsetzen
können denn drei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl ist die spd stärkste
kraft about den abstand zur union sogar
weiter aus olaf scholz liegt in der
wählergunst weit vor armin laschet was
muss dann der kanzlerkandidat der union
jetzt aus ihrer sicht tun um das ruder
doch noch herumzureißen
er muss nicht nur jetzt sondern wir
machen es bereits so nicht nur armin
laschet alleine sondern wir als cdu mit
der csu gemeinsam als union wir machen
weiter wir treten für unsere inhalte ein
nicht nur für einen kanzlerkandidaten
und dahinter kommt da nix sondern für
uns als union wir haben nicht nur die
inhalte wir haben vor allen dingen auch
viele kolleginnen und kollegen die
einfach top fachpolitiker fach
politikerinnen sind und wir gemeinsam
wollen den wähler die wählerinnen
überzeugen sie sagen inhalte aber ich
höre vor allem vor allem aus dem munde
von armin laschet aber auch markus söder
warnungen vor einem linksbündnis also
vor einem rot grün roten bündnis unter
einem kanzler scholz der wiederum so
dass unions negativ dann zur marionette
von ascon und kümmerte würde aber auch
das scheint bei den wählern nicht zu
verfangen laut zdf-politbarometer wäre
ein linksbündnis im moment sogar
beliebter als eine jamaika koalition
genau diese frage ist doch die zentrale
wollen wir ein linksbündnis für
deutschland oder wollen wir eine
bürgerlich geführte bundesregierung und
für uns ist das verbunden nicht mit zwei
köpfen sondern mit den themen wofür die
beiden verschiedenen varianten am ende
für unser land dann auch stehen und
darauf kommt es doch an wollen wir
steuererhöhungen oder wollen wir einen
turbo für unsere wirtschaft und das
können wir auf alle themen ausweiten und
deswegen wollen wir einen inhaltlichen
wahlkampf machen und für unser angebot
kämpfen aber bliebe es bei den jetzigen
umfragewerten dann gäbe es für die union
nach dem 26 september nur noch eine
einzige option um den kanzler zu stellen
nämlich eine jamaika koalition mit fdp
und grünen
also ausgerechnet mit der partei die
ihre leute ja gerne als verbots partei
anprangern de wieviel selbstverleugnung
wäre der union der machterhalt wird
erst mal geht es um die bundestagswahl
und noch nicht um koalitionsgespräche
und auch noch nicht um irgendwelche
posten wir kämpfen stunde um stunde tag
um tag dafür die wähler von wählerinnen
von uns zu überzeugen und von unseren
inhalten und alles andere diskutieren
wir anschließend sie kämpfen twenty four
seven wie sie sagen den eindruck hat man
jetzt von der kanzlerin nicht unbedingt
da gibt es eher sagen wir mal
überschaubare wahlkampfhilfe gestern
immerhin einmal der satz wer so ein land
nämlich nordrhein westfalen führen kann
sagt merkel kann auch die bundesrepublik
deutschland als kanzler führen also ich
sag mal überzeugte oder gar überzeugende
unterstützung von merkel für laschet
würde sich vermutlich anders anhören
oder
unsere bundeskanzlerin ist überzeugt von
armin laschet und sie hat schon vielfach
an verschiedensten stellen zum ausdruck
gebracht und ich glaube da ist kritik
auch an unsere kanzlerin völlig
unangebracht dann lassen wir das mal so
stehen und danke der stellvertretenden
cdu vorsitzenden silvia breher die eben
neuen zukunfts team von armin laschet
für familienpolitik zuständig ist danke
nach cloppenburg
dankeschön eine schöne woche